the episode that we're shooting now it's
about California and how we're seeing
the effects of climate change here
dramatically here with temperatures
rising and us losing the snowpack how
that is having an effect on water
specifically and how the lack of water
is affecting everyone down the line
we're in Tulare County California which
is one of the most important crop
growing areas not just of California not
just of the United States but of the
world and they've been like the rest of
California in drought for over four
years now in the Central Valley is right
now dying in front of us so because of
the drought they're forced to only use
water from their wells which means
they're sucking up all the groundwater
wells are going dry and the groundwater
itself is becoming depleted so this is
it yeah this canal here has been dry for
going on almost three years three years
like this we are relying so much on
things that we have no control over I
mean the big picture in all of it is
worrying the real world struggles that
we're going to face if this situation
continues you know I'm confident that
we'll survive but I think the drought
has given us the opportunity to do this
to share our stories and the fruit that
comes from farming and how it feeds
everybody so when we have rain we'll
we'll continue to farm we'll make crops
and we'll continue to feed the world we
do know with climate change droughts are
going to be more frequent and of longer
duration and people who farm here have
got to learn to live in a new
environment which means the rest of the
country and the rest of the world has to
learn to live with that new environment
it's alarming there's no time to waste
we have to bang on the drum and try to
get as much attention as we can however
we can
you